hey everyone welcome back I'm going to
do another live commentary Blitz video
except it's not actually live it's kind
of pseudo live commentary but I'm
sharing another game I played in Vegas
just over a week ago I played against
version okobian in the Walter Brown
Memorial Blitz we played two really
really interesting crazy hard-fought
games you can see the first game that we
played in this one and without further
Ado enjoy the video let's get into the
live commentary
so I start with D4
he plays E6
and we had a small issue with the clock
getting it to start chess clocks can be
confusing sometimes
but eventually we managed Bishop F4
Knight F6 E3
now he plays B6 and I was happy to play
this on Queen F3 which is a tricky line
and he uh had a bit of hesitation here I
actually played this line against him in
a Blitz game about two years ago online
which I remembered because we did like a
collaboration on Twitch yeah this was
actually be played by my student against
me oh and and he might have seen it from
your streams my one of my new students
are Franco so he played against me this
and uh and first I didn't know anything
about it then I looked at it and I
realized that there was there were games
played in this with shimanov and a few
other Grand Masters I'll have to dig up
the footage for Matt but he beat me in
that game
but um I was still happy to get this
variation knew the basic plans to go for
this pawnage for which is one of the top
engine ideas the idea is to get the pawn
to each five
and speaking of the engine I'm actually
going to turn on the eval bar
just because we're going to see some
crazy fluctuations later
but one of the ideas of putting the pawn
on H5 is with the setup of Bishop F4 and
Queen on G3 black does not have Knight
H5 because a rook now covers H5
so it's a little bit awkward for that
he'd play C5
and now I take some time because I
wanted to play Bishop C7 But ultimately
I decided to play Knight F3
afterwards I'll I'll analyze the funny
lines that could have happened with
Bishop C7
and still in the opening phase Knight
bd7
and this position I Castle
which I thought is a very normal move
but it turns out to be
a bit of a mistake because now my king
is a ripe Target for a queen side attack
and he really wasted no time before
playing B5
and now I'm realizing this Pawn storm is
coming very very quickly
the nice thing is I do have a small Edge
on the clock
I take on C5
and I'm up about 40 seconds he's falling
below two minutes
he's taking a lot of time in the opening
but probably for good reason because
malbach is getting a lot of initiative
my Knight has to move away from C3
and it's a difficult spot because
wherever I move my Knights this Knight
E4 move is coming
so at this point I'm realizing
I'm in a little bit of trouble
and I'm also burning away my time
advantage
so I decided on Knight A4
and then he instantly plays Knight E4
and I'm realizing oh no my Queen's
attacked and it's tied down to F2
I've abandoned my F Pawn but I figure
that I should still try and play quickly
and try and get some compensation try
and treat the blunder as a gambits and
if he takes on F2 maybe I can just
develop a sack The Exchange and still
get some activity in the middle game
and he took some time here because
Knight F2 is not the only candidate move
he also has moves like Queen A5 hitting
the Knight or Knight takes C5
but he decides on Rook C8
putting more pressure against the pawn
leaving F2 still attacked
I'm trying to figure out how to do
damage control
I hesitate a bit
like I'm looking for moves to defend
my very tender f-pawn
but I also want to make sure the queen
side's under control I do play G4
so defending the F Pawn with the queen
but now he just gets monster initiative
on the queen side
Queen A5 attack in the knights provoking
B3 he takes on C5
and I'm realizing that most of my pieces
are stuck on the king side
not defending my king which is on the
queen side
and this is where
I'm losing a little bit of focus
in my head but also in the camera oh no
my focus
this only lasts a few more seconds I
think
so hopefully we can still see the
position clearly
Bishop D3 played
but we can see the eval bar
very much in box favor he takes on A4
I take back
and my shelter for my king is just
gradually crumbling
and this position
[Music]
there's a lot of attractive moves for
black
but he's still taking time I realized my
hope in this game is probably on the
clock so I still play quickly
I got rid of the night I didn't want to
allow Knight C3
he recaptures
and I played Knight D4 nice Central
Square defending the C2 Pawn
but I still have a ton of worries in the
position given that the C files open A2
is hanging
he starts with Bishop C5 threatening to
take the Knight and then checkmates on
C2
so I'm looking for ways to defend I play
Knight B3 obstructing the queen holding
on to the Knight
A2 is still undefended and he snags it I
play Bishop E5
there's actually a nice word for the
bishop
essentially a wooden Shield
xqc would be proud
attacking uh the pawn on G7 also helping
defend some key squares
and he's still taking time falling below
20 seconds plays F6
I dropped the bishop back to B2
and he castles
and then I play G5 I really spent no
time on this move it was more of a gut
instinct trying to just create chaos in
the position I realize that I'm in
trouble so why not make things messy
a bishop D5 was a really nice move
adding another attacker
I get rid of the bishop sacrificing the
rook and then I take on each six
and this is where the whole position
just explodes he sacrifices his Queen
because if I take then he has Bishop D6
Discovery so I take on G7 hitting the
Rook is Queen still undefended he plays
rogoff seven I play H6 I don't want to
take his Queen and allow Bishop D6 after
takes takes
King H7 black hitting my Pawns
I feel like the momentum is Shifting but
how to make progress with my kingside
pawns I play King B1 he takes on E3
I'm just trying to find a way to get to
his King
I'm also getting low on time
falling below 40 seconds play Queen H5
hitting the Rook threatening Queen F5 at
this point I think I'm winning but he
has Queen F3
attacking my queen and also hitting the
Rook
so I take on F7 he takes on H1 I play
King A2 I still think I'm winning here
but after Rook G8
queen of six
he takes on each six Queen F5
Queen G6
Queen H3 I have at least a perpetual
I also have a little bit of time on the
clock so I'm searching for some way to
try and play for a win
But ultimately I decide that that's not
worth
playing another move then uh
and continuing the checks like Queen H3
Queen H6
Queen F5 and we agree to withdraw not
the firmest of handshakes but I think we
were both a little bit disappointed that
we didn't take advantage of Our Winning
chances I think VAR was probably more
disappointed given that he had such a
crushing position in the middle game
so let's hop into some analysis and just
share a bunch of the critical moments
because there's so much to learn there's
so many moments where black had a
knockout blow I missed a at least one
knockout blow and it started with a
really fun opening this uh
non-traditional London the early Queen
to F3 as I mentioned it's an opening I
played against VAR online a couple years
ago and it's a nice surprise weapon
um I played this a good handful of times
in bullets where players preview Bishop
B7
and I just win the bishop and just uh
instantly win the game pretty much but
of course
um he didn't blunder material he played
D5
and the first moment I want to show is
after Queen G3 C5 the engine actually
likes to move Bishop C7 in this position
and I didn't take too much time here
because I played Knight F3 pretty
quickly but Bishop C7 is a very
adventurous line which I think would
have been risky for whites if I toggle
it on
um yeah Stockbridge says white slightly
preferable here
but after Queen C8 takes Knight t7 the
bishop would be forced to a five and
it's a very computer-ish way of playing
that
um I I didn't really put much time
towards considering during the game
so uh what happened was after Knight F3
Knight D7 I think the first big mistake
on my part was casting queenside
because this just walks straight into
his attack
and very often white does Castle Queen
side in this in this line but I should
have realized that back is in very good
shape to attack and probably held off
engine suggesting Bishop D3 or 95 just
more centralizing moves
but after castling in B5 things only got
worse for me because after takes
before
uh yeah I just went downhill very
quickly uh Knight A4 turned out to be a
big plunder
the engine says Bishop C7 is only way
not to be losing for white to basically
prevent the queen from eventually coming
to A5 and after Queen E7 there's Bishop
T6 and maybe there's some potential
repetition and if Queen C8 I think the
idea here is after Knight A4 Knight E4
I was going to say I have the H4 Square
for the queen
but maybe there's there's some
compensation like Queen F4 and even if
Knight takes F2
yeah there's a lot of potential
compensation like P6 somehow White's
battery here
but going back to what happened the game
I played Knight A4
and then
it was just basically trying to deal
with this Non-Stop
blurry of punches Rook C8 can I defend
F2 and then he plays Queen A5 like every
move it felt like I was getting punched
in the face
and we see the engine like already
giving minus eights in Black's favor
and there's actually a moment uh going
back before Queen takes A4 there's an
amazing knockout blow here for black
pawn B3
and I mean this would have been the way
of the engine just destroys white in
this position because my C Pawn is
pinned and if a takes B3 there's Bishop
A3
King B1 Knight C3
and yeah it's minus 20. Knight takes A4
sacrificing the knights if I take then
Queen C3 is uh Force mate
um otherwise Queen C3 is still coming
and it's not pretty Bishop E5 Knight C3
back eventually the engine will find
some Force mates
minus 24.
so I was lucky to survive after Queen
digs A4 getting rid of the knights
and this goes to show that even when the
engine says one side is completely
winning sometimes in a a Blitz game
between humans it's not so simple
and he still found a lot of good moves
like Bishop C5 was a great move
and then Queen takes A2 and
um F6 this is all fine for black I was
holding on by the thread
and I think after casting this is
maybe the moment where I had a glimmer
of hope with this move Pawn G5
just doing anything possible to try and
break through I was really happy with
this move because black either has to
allow taking on each six or if he takes
with H Pawn I have Pawn H6 White's
actually winning here and it takes with
the F Pawn then I have Rook D7
which uh in black is still okay if he
finds Rook F7 but at least white has
some initiative
so G5 definitely muddied the waters and
after Bishop D5
takes takes
black is still winning according to the
engine but we're gonna see that in order
for him to win he has to find some
difficult moves and he actually found
Queen takes B3 one of the winning moves
sacrificing the queen
but after takes
he played Rook F7
and then gradually it got
um more and more tricky because I'm
threatening to play H7
and after Bishop takes E3 evaluation
swings now White's winning
um the only winning move for black in
this position
was to forcibly sacrifice the queen
queen takes C2
it's the only way to keep enough
initiative and simplify King takes C2
Bishop D6 I'd move the king he takes
takes and then I'm not even threatening
H7
and yeah I mean maybe it still takes
some technique King H7 nice move to
blockade I mean this should be winning
but still takes word for vac
but going back to what happened the game
I was winning after Bishop takes E3
because after it takes
okay he played King H7
I missed the only completely winning
move here now I played King B1 which is
still keeping an edge for whites but
there's a really nice move Queen F2
covering E3 keeping C2 defended and
threatening Queen F5
and yeah if Pawn F5 then
yeah there's some crazy engine sequence
um suggesting promote to a bishop
oh starfish is so Savage promotes a
bishop or queen works but the point is
that the Rook is tied down to pinning
the pawn so if Rook takes I take the
queen for free and if King takes then I
essentially sacrifice the other pawn and
then the king's left very naked the
engine says there's force made here I'll
just press spacebar to see the force
mates
uh yeah this is pretty brutal
I don't even have to take the queen in
the end
made his imminence
so I miss queen F2
it was hard to find an under time
pressure
I played the move King B1
and he takes on E3
I played Queen H5 white is still winning
but the only way to win in this position
is to promote
and I mean given the fact that I only
had a few seconds to make my next move
it's just it was too tempting to take
the Rook
um the reason why promoting is better is
because
white wants to create a situation where
I take the Rook with check so after
takes takes this is completely winning
because F6 is hanging next
and if King takes then H7
and if takes and I take and it's winning
if King h8 takes and this is different
compared to what we got in the game
because F6 is just falling and I guess
there is D4 like there's some crazy
engine lines here Queen F6 King H7 I win
The Rook eventually
but then it still takes a lot of
technique to win
yeah anything could have happened
so going back I missed my shot to
promote I took the rook and now black is
winning again because after takes here
uh Rook G8
what happened the game he has a move
Queen F3 here
and this is winning for black because I
don't have Queen F5 check my pawns are
blockaded
and there's actually no good way for
white to make progress if Queen takes A6
then black can start pushing the pawn
and the king is actually quite safe on
H7
size fortunate that instead of finding
this winning move Queen F3
he took on H6
and then the game ended peacefully
as we saw
so as a crazy roller coaster game
just for fun let me show the engine
graph because I did do the the engine
analysis here
and we can see the graph
okay I was better after the opening
and then it just went downhill he was
winning for most of the middle game
and then things turned around and I was
winning
and then he was winning again
and there was a draw so we both played
at 78 accuracy he made two blunders I
made four blunders that's the nature of
Blitz chess hope you guys were
entertained and you stay tuned for the
next video where we'll have another
crazy battle to witness
and again hope you guys enjoyed this if
you like it leave a comment subscribe
and I'll see you guys in the next video